joining us now a man who won Super Bowl
45 in Dallas now he will be coaching the
Dallas Cowboys
he is new Cowboys coach Mike McCarthy
coach great to see you how's everything
it's uh it's going it's going well it's
good to be here finding my footing I
can't get used to seeing you
first of all in blue instead of green
and second of all with that star how
long did it take you to get used to the
concept Packers anymore now Cowboys well
I think you know I think having the year
off you had a chance to kind of dissolve
yourself from the green but no it's been
it's been a smooth change really I think
that's the the parallels between the
organization's you know is there's a lot
of things in common so it's great to
jump back into it so we like to blue
a lot of guys have coached multiple
teams and I can't think of a guy who's
coached to really high profile teams
passionate fan bases tons of pressure I
suppose all the time in Green Bay helps
prepare you for stepping into an even
bigger spotlight in Dallas I would say
so Mike I think like anything in life if
you have past experiences that you can
pull forward this is definitely the case
but with that very blessed it's a
privilege to coach in both organizations
but just really the uniqueness of Dallas
it's really what you know I'm focused on
and and that's the beauty of year one
you know you're one you just kind of
jump in there and you just keep going
and things are starting to come together
but very very fortunate very blessed for
this opportunity you know it's funny
when I was growing up not far from
Pittsburgh I mean you would think the
big rivals the Browns or the bang its
the Cowboys where the Steelers bigger so
everybody hated the Cowboys because they
kept crossing paths in the Super Bowl
how much grief have you gotten from
folks back home that you're now the
coach to the team that was so hated by
the Steelers and the fans in the 70s I
think things are different today you
know I think everybody's such an NFL fan
but but I do remember the 70s I mean
they were those were great years in
Pittsburgh but the one thing I do recall
is you probably throw to Dallas was
always the second game and and I think
for all of us back in Pittsburgh it kind
of changed when Tony Dorsett went there
because you know he's so on that I know
I enjoyed watching as a young kid when
he was playing at Pitt and when he went
to the Cowboys I think everybody wanted
to keep it up keep an eye on Tony so we
both remember when he was Tony Dorsett
yeah but no I mean it's such a great
career with such an exciting person so
you know I've always you know been in
tune with with the Cowboys and the great
teams they had and obviously the great
Super Bowls at the head with Pittsburgh
you know it's kind of weird we're both
in that same area where football is such
an important part of life when did you
realize that that was kind of your
destiny professionally well I was saying
in college when I had the opportunity to
coach at the University of Pittsburgh
back in 1989 just my particular you know
situation growing up in an intercity
Pittsburgh we didn't really have we
didn't have youth football you really
didn't have the opportunity to Blaine so
you got the high school so baseball and
basketball were my first two sports that
I did I loved in Excel but once I had
the opportunity to play in high school I
just fell in love with the sport and
when I had the opportunity to the
volunteer pit that's that's when I knew
this is what I this is what I want to do
and in chase the chase that professional
and now you're with the Cowboys and dak
Prescott the quarterback and you had the
benefit I mean you've had Brett Favre
then Aaron Rodgers now that Prescott
when you watch that Prescott's film what
kind of ideas do you have what kind of
inspiration do you have of how you can
make him into the best version of that
Prescott he can be well you know we're
we're in our second lap as it was what
we refer to as a offense and even a
defensive staff where we've had a chance
to go through you know every snap from
last year and just really watch the
players on how they put you know how
they performed in last year's system and
I think that the obvious is you know
with Dax film is it just just jumped the
big playability I think thinking over
number Dallas was number one in the
league and big play production
particularly to drop back passing game
so his ability to make throws from the
pocket I think we we all know his
ability you know outside the pocket
ability to run the football but was so
impressed with the number of throws he
made in the
akkad particularly down-filled so you
know and with that you know we everybody
wants to compare Brett and Aaron and and
it obviously it'll be the same with dak
but there every one of those guys is
different to their you know to their
style of play and you know I'm just I'm
just excited to you know put this new
offense together and get started get
started to work with them when you study
offense and defense and special teams
from the Cowboys last year how do you
diagnose what went wrong to cause them
to land at eight and eight and on the
wrong side of the playoff picture well I
think like anything I you know when you
have time to reflect and it's really the
whole football operations is it's
usually not never just one thing so and
with that you know we've tried to you
know absorb as much as as we can of the
things we want to carry forward because
there's you know so many positive
attributes that are already in place
there but when you talk about the pure
performance when you look at the offense
you have to you have to look at the
point the point generation if you look
at the you know the scores of the game
you know fit below 15 points in the
losses and above I think 31 in the winds
so I mean I so with that you the level
of consistency will be part of our our
flight you know coming into the new year
which is you know for every every every
coach and every team you're looking for
that so just a level of consistency in
point production defensively it's gonna
be a whole it's against gonna be a whole
still change schematically and flood
philosophical get it's gonna be
different for our guys and and that
definitely holds true also special teams
with with John fossil how hard was it to
be away from the sport that you love for
a full year I mean I know you were
working behind the scenes and you had a
plan and you were staying active and you
were kind of everything was leading up
to this but still to not be in the fight
to not be in the fray for a full year
what was that like for you you know it
was it was so different than I thought
it was going to be and I think like all
of us you never really think about it
but it was it was clearly the best
decision that I made for my family and I
and
and I'm so thankful for it you know it
really was a gift for us to take a step
back you know we're a blended family so
we have a lot of moving parts and really
just to collect myself professionally a
very thankful for and just made the best
of it but yeah it's difficult I mean I'm
not gonna lie to you walk in here
yesterday and you know you know this the
the feelings come back and you the faces
you haven't seen in in over a year so
it's a blessing to work in the National
Football League I mean just just to
think that we get to do this every day
what we love I mean talk football every
day just I mean the X and O
conversations going back through the
film last year and building a new
offense you know looking at the
schedules from Green Bay and how you can
get a plateau just all those things so
I'm thankful for the break but you know
just real excited about this next
opportunity you coached the team from
2006 into 2018 that doesn't have an
owner at all publicly-owned Green Bay
Packers there isn't that one person who
can roll out of bed and even day and
come in and just create chaos if they
want to and now you're at the other
extreme you're working for the owner the
guy with the bus Jerry Jones I mean I
can't imagine the contrast for you to
have no one in that position to having
the guy who when you think NFL owner
nowadays you think Jerry Jones
definitely and I think we said earlier
there's the comparables are are in place
there when you look at no owner versus
verson owner but the thing that is so
consistent in Green Bay we always felt
that we were you know football family
family first operation and you see that
right away in Dallas I mean this is a
family owned business I mean Jerry and
his family are very close and in
in the vibe that goes through that whole
building is is about though it's about
winning but you know it definitely has
that family first vibe to it and and I
love that so it's that that part has
been very natural it's it's been
exciting but you know yeah it's you know
I think it's never the same I mean it's
never the same year to year but yeah I'm
excited about the setup that we have in
Dallas
Jerry Jones has made no bones over the
last eight years or so about his urgency
to get back to his Super Bowl and win it
this is a team that hasn't even been in
the NFC championship since 1995 how do
you try to get folks in the organization
maybe it's gonna take a little time it's
not like you just show up and putting
put together a Super Bowl team we got
some changes we need to make we got some
people we need to get we got some
systems we need to get in place we can't
have the bar too high but we're just
gonna end up being disappointed again
well I think like anything not to get in
the coach speak I mean you have to trust
the process but it's really defining
what the process is the details of its
staying true to it the bumps are coming
but you know having a proactive approach
to what the issues are going to be here
the here are the answers ahead of time
this is how we're going to handle it so
that's all part of it I always go back
to the the championship here in Green
Bay it you know it took 77 players of
the win a Super Bowl so just you know
you look at those past experience and
how you can apply that you know to here
in Dallas and you know and that's why
we're here it's player acquisition time
you can never have enough good players
so and you know so just staying true to
that process and and you know you need a
little luck long way you know health is
very important
so just staying true to that well love
them or hate them the Cowboys continue
to be America's team the head coach of
America's team from the Packers of the
Cowboys it will be great to see how it
plays out we love watching the Cowboys
we love getting them in primetime
everybody watches them when they're on
TV so we're gonna be seeing plenty of
Michael McCarthy on the sidelines this
year coach thanks for some of your time
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports